Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Eleanor's Stairway!
Now this is just a demo and I believe it's a short demo to a game that is not released yet or may have been canceled.
I'm not a 100% sure on the status of the whole game
but I have to say that this looks... phenomenal.
Like it really does look good.
And I think it was inspired by, or at least some form of adaptation from Silent Hill P.T.
Or the 'playable teaser' cause it's called Eleanor's Stairway playable teaser.
But it looks like someone had a party here and I wasn't invited. >:(
Why?! I'm a cool guy that likes to party and stuff.
I'm not an introvert that sits at home alone, *giggle* playing video games all day.
Wow! This looks ... Hey...Oh, hi. How's it going?
Well...
this house is too fancy for my taste and holy crap it is just going nuts out there.
Now what's even more amazing is that this game is made in Unity and I usually don't see...
good graphics like this in Unity running very well all that often.
Holy crap. What is that? Just a drop into the abyss?!
What is this? S... SCP-087-B?
*sound of metal soda can falling and laughing*
Whoa, hey, thank you. Hi!
Oh!
Is that supposed to look like a figure of a man?
Ah! It just looks so cool.
OK. Hello? Ah, yeah. OK. Alright.
Loooong narrow hallway with NOTHING BEHIND ME!
NOTHING!
*main character footsteps*
Okay, we're fine.
Hello! Ka-chunk. Ahhh! It so is!!! That's awe-
*woman crying*
Hi.
*woman crying intensifies*
Hey?
*woman continues crying at life*
Okay...
*woman still crying*
Okay, I think she's just gonna keep crying like that...
*multiple knocks*
Hi! Oh! That's a lot of noises happenin'.
*woman crying and knocking intensifies*
Oh geez! Man...
Ooookay... *ominous music* No, grandma!
Oh boy!
*sounds of crying, static, and siren-like noises*
Oh!
*sounds of crying, static, and siren-like noises continue*
Well, that is exceptionally disconcerting
*sounds of crying, static, and siren-like noises still going*
I'm starting to get spooped up in here!
It's geting real spoopy. Oh geez! Ugh geez!
Alright, let me escape the wails of the damned for a second.
To find the source of all the- Oooooooh! Heeeeeey! Oh-ho my god!
Hi! Were you the one crying?
Am I supposed the be expected to walk toward you twitchy face?
Oh goddamn...
"FloatyFeet McTwitchyface" over here.
Don't come charging at me.
If you do, I will be so pissed. Anything behind me?
No! Alright give 'big daddy Markiplier' ;) a big old hug.
Come on! Ugh... OH HEY!
*crying slows down*
Goodbye? Hello?
*crying continues then abruptly stops*
Okay... Oh good!
Alright, let's go for one more loop, why
not? Oh, I've been having fun.
Why not continue on with the party? Holy shit...
Okay.
Well then.
*quiet footsteps of the main character*
Okay... Is the statue still there? Yeah still there.
Looking creepier than ever.
Still there.
Hi grandma.
Sorry about the illumination going away from your face.
You were just too ugly for this world
apparently.
*door creaking open; sharp inhale*
Hiii..- Oh hi!
*crying*
*screams* AH WHAT THE FUCK?! AM I SUPPOSED TO GO DOWN?!
What the fuck? Am I supposed to go down? Oh. Ok.
OH.
*crying*
Okay!?
What do I do? Oh geez, oh geez, oh geez. Ahhh! She's coming for me.
Oh shit, she's coming for me for. Oh shit, she's coming me! Heeeey lady...
Oh, geez. *laughs* Your lack of animation is awfully disturbing.
*high pitched screaming* Open the door! *high pitched scream*
Heh.
*static* Ugh- oh hi! Oh. Hey! Oh. Uh oh. That ain't good.
That ain't good at all.
*confused groaning*
*static
*static stops as game ends*
Okay..
AWWW NOOOOOOO...
NOOO... THAT WAS IT!? Oh, that was so short!
Oh no! That was well made!
Oh, that was really well made! Awwww, man!
Oh, it was so- aww, man. It's always like-
these really cool indie horror games.
Y'know, they take so much work and it's usually just like one guy doing it. So,
having it all crammed into one game
often means that there's not as much as
you would want out of a cool experience
like this. But this is really good!
I really don't know what the status of
this project is... but this is well done. And-
That's- that's really nice. Okay. But either way
this is really well done you can check
this out for yourself. I'll put a link to
the... the game development page.
I hope it's still going on whoever the
developer is, this looks great.
You got a lot of talent. This is good stuff
here. So, thank you everybody so much for
watching! And as always, I will see YOU... in
the next video!
BUH-BYE!
*outro music: "Haunted" by Shirk*